hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I'm sure you've seen the trailer by now
for Battlefront 2 and if you were like
me you may have been a little
underwhelmed at first with your reaction
something like me well you would be
wrong and I'm not afraid to admit it I
was wrong too
so after sifting through all the
information available I've come up with
17 things you need to know about
Battlefront 2 okay let's do this
Battlefront to have a single-player
campaign yes I know that shouldn't be
big news but the first title was
multiplayer only making this an
essential area to start of course the
multiplayer side of things will be the
core of the game just like battlefield
Call of Duty and pretty much every
first-person shooter in recent memory
but this one has something that will
make even the most casual fans of Star
Wars reach for their lightsabers the
story it has been confirmed that the
battlefront 2 story will be canon just
in case you don't know what that means
battlefront 2 story is officially part
of the Star Wars lineage this is not
fanfiction this is not an alternative
timeline this is legit it gets even
better the narrative will pick up at the
end of Return of the Jedi
just as the desktop version 2 blows up
so basically just that the little [ __ ]
czar celebrating with ghosts and where
will it conclude at the start of the
force awakens this story will span 30
years and will fill the gaps the films
are yet to speak about such as how did
the first-order grow so quickly - and
what happened to those little [ __ ] on
Endor I hope they died little this is
the perfect time to introduce the mid
protagonist in the battlefront 2 story I
didn't versio a cop I pronounced that
right we'll be in the booth of an
imperial soldier yeah that's right we're
on the side of the buddies but remember
no one is the bad guy in their own story
so expect to care about the dark side in
a way you haven't before and we all know
the dark side is far more exciting than
the boring light side
iDEN watches her way of life blow up in
front of her eyes and will most likely
be looking for a revenge over those
little bastard he walks maybe not maybe
she'll just be gunning for the rebels
luckily she's the commanding officer of
infernal squad an elite special forces
unit skilled in space combat and ground
invasions we're playing as the bad guy
in the story of revenge maybe it's just
me but that sounds absolutely epic and
look she's about to shoot Luke Skywalker
but we all know he's still alive or this
can't end well for the Inferno squad
returning characters can be seen
throughout the trailer including Darth
Maul Luke and even that little green
goblin Yoda and the new trilogy
characters kylo Ren and Rey as well it's
pretty safe to expect to interact with
your favorite characters from all the
films or at least fight alongside them
at one point this could mean we may have
to murder Jar Jar Binks how satisfying
would that be ah ether swamp trail is
just like Mesa I would convince them of
our good fellowship before I pass out
from excitement let's jump over to the
multiplayer side of things and confirm
that maps from all three Star Wars
generations will be available so we
could be scrapping away on vardø or
Naboo and then jump over to Cloud City
and we could be even fighting on Hoth
which when you think about it should be
called cold really not off anyway moving
on different character classes have been
confirmed involving those that were
quite weak in a battle front would for
confirmed thus far they are officer
heavy assault and specialists which can
be customized to suit your playstyle
much closer to battlefield and caught in
that respect this is the element of
depth in the games most probably the XP
that we gain from completing missions
will go towards unlocks such as weapons
and characters moving of course there
are deluxe version and pre-order bonuses
available of this game we do a plethora
of things the first lets you upgrade the
extra mentioned character classes
instantly and unspecified XQ bility will
be upgraded and mods will be unlocked
right away there's many more little big
areas like that so we'll review that
plus to the time once again multiplayer
will have 40 players simultaneously back
it's a pretty substantial amount if
you've ever played 64-player battlefield
you know that that can be a veritable
turd storm of activity similarly if you
played 12 player destiny it can
sometimes feel quite sparse on the
battlefield could 40 be the perfect
number or do you think about that please
let me know below hey guys have you
noticed that I've referenced battlefield
regularly through this video
well that's because dice the developer
behind that theory it's also behind
battle fruits so we already know they
have the pedigree to deliver and the
ability to improve the original
battlefront title you keep this so much
where you'll be dead in a month they've
also worked on Mirror's Edge and
pinball's dreams ok that last one was a
bit terrible but you get the idea
Star Wars has a rich history of vehicles
both on land and aerospace rather so
it's next battlefront 2 to be filled
with x-wings TIE fighters speeders and
look it's a bloody target on oh one more
thing what is this big booger is it an
8080 or is it an at-at it's an asset
right let me know what you call it below
please at this point space battles have
been confirmed to support 24 players one
last thing for multiplayer split-screen
co-op has been confirmed this is only
available offline at present so you'll
be facing box rather than real people
but still useful to know so if you have
a couch and you're looking enough to
have a real-life friend then join up and
fight together you can also use this
function on your ps4 using sheer clay so
if your mate doesn't own battlefront 2
then don't worry about it you can still
play together and I'm sure many trophy
hunters will use this excessively the
worldwide release of battlefront 2 is
November the 17th keep that in mind
because there is already a Star Wars
battle for 2 game available but it did
release in 2005 did anybody play it it
was pretty damn good actually the
producers of battlefront 2 have said the
game will not require a season pass so
basically the initial price of the game
is all you need to purchase to stay with
all other users this is taken a page out
of blizzards groundbreaking overwatch
which is rewriting the rulebook around
online shooters by making all DLC 3 the
community will not fragment due to those
pay while
like battlefield for demonstrate and
this should add years to the play cycle
of battlefront to a few little things
before we end this video if you want to
know more about the origins of infernal
squad then there is a comic book coming
out just for you it's in response to
what happens at the end of rogue one
I want to spoil it so you already know
what happened the Empire's Imperial Navy
have authorized this elite group of
soldiers to be called infernal squad so
if you want to be a step ahead of the
story then you can grab that on July
25th so that's it that's 17 things you
should know about Star Wars Battlefront
2 things are looking good on paper but
keep in mind we haven't seen any real
gameplay yet but it's a safe assumption
to expect improved visuals and
animations from the 2015 game I
personally did not expect to be so
excited about this game but dammit I am
what do you think are you going to pick
it up and now you buying it for the
story or the multiplayer or books I
imagine from PlayStation grenades and if
this was useful please choke us a like
and think about subscribing I'll see you
next time